اختبار لفحص الدم يبحث عن التغيرات
الكيميائيه المبكره التي تحدث في الحمض
النووي وفي الخلايا التي بدا يغزوها
السرطان وبامكانه اخبارها عن مكان وجود
المراه وتحديده مسبقا وذلك من خلال ارسال
الاشاره مثلا بانه يوجد في البنكرياسي او
المبيض او في الغدد اللمفاويه
كل هذا من خلال عربه متنقله في مدينه كنز
في انجلترا مخصصه لفحص الدم للكشف المبكر
يعني السرطان تضم طاقه من الطبيه المتخصصه
في اجراء هذه الاختبارات
240,000 شخص في دراسه اختبار يمكن للكشف
عن اكثر من 50 نوع من السرطان قبل ظهور
الاعراب وتقوم عربه الفحص المتنقله بجوله
بثمن مناطق في انجلترا لجميع عينات من
المشاركين الذين تتراوحوا اعمائهم بين
الخمسين والسبعين
بيتزا جونسون مدير المستشفى الوطني
للسرطان في انجلترا قال انه في حال نجاح
التجربه يمكن تقديم الفحص بشكل روتيني
ويمكن ايضا تطبيقه كبرنامج فحص وطني
ويحذر الخبراء من ان برنامج الفحص الوطني
قد يعطي نتائج ايجابيه كاذبه مما يتسبب في
قلق المرضى ويزيد الضغط على العيادات لكن
الاطباء يعملون ان يعزز الاختبار من
معدلات النجاه من سرطان بالكشف عن المرض
المبكرا مما يوفر الوقت والمال